bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce 21e des binaires et tout dernier
webinaire avant les congés d'été
j'espère que vous portez bien et donc
aujourd'hui nous allons continuer pour
une cinquième session sur d'autres
exemples de trajectoire de soins on
l'aura vu c'est un exemple qui nous aura
suivi déjà maintenant depuis quelques
semaines on avait déjà fait une première
description des données on avait abordé
une analyse de survie classique donc
avec le temps entre le diagnostic et la
première entrée en soins la première
initiation traitement et latin de la
charge virale comprenez on avait vu que
sur cette analyse de survie en prenant
compte que le premier événement de
chaque type qu'un seul élément la
transition donc on avait voulu aborder
ça de manière un peu plus complexe bien
et de l'analyse séquence le but de
l'analyse de séquences c'était justement
de pouvoir prenant compte des des bars
des transitions plus complexes et
notamment des retours en arrière
l'analyse à cinq ans nous avait permis
de pouvoir faire une catégorisation
n'avait pour le coup retenu 4 e classe à
quatre modalités avec des rapides d'élan
d'eysines abouti et d'erreurs soins et
nous avions la semaine dernière aborder
par le biais d'une régression logistique
multimodale les facteurs associés à
chacune de ces deux ses classes et en
toute fin de session nous avions vu la
semaine dernière très rapidement et une
très courte introduction au modèle mixa
qu'un seul attentes qui étaient une
manière alternative d'aborder d'abord
des ducs une classification mais qui
permettait on en compte l'ensemble du
jeu de données puisque ses modèles à
permettent de tenir compte qu'on a eu
des trajectoires plus ou moins longue
là où dans l'analyse de séquences nous
avions restera finalement notre analyse
à 18 mois et uniquement aux individus
et au moins 18 mois ce que je vous
propose aujourd'hui on va aborder
d'autres manières d'appréhender le même
jeu de données et on va en fait
regardez comment est-ce qu'on peut les
aborder sous la forme d'un modèle
observations répétées
alors je vous propose de zoomer je vous
remets l'interface de studio voyez comme
les dernières fois j'ai j'ai sorti un le
projet le même projet nous avons ici le
script qui nous avait servi la semaine
dernière ce que je vais faire je vais en
faire une nouvelle version vous l'aurez
compris engenio parfois l'habitude quand
il ya des grands changements à verscio
nez mais mes scripts pour garder un
historique et donc que je vais mettre à
jour la date est normalement il avait
gardé en mémoire vous voyez là j'ai
encore mes différents objets mais si je
vais être sûr d'avoir les objets dans le
même état ce que je peux faire vous
l'avez déjà vu je vais faire brice taton
un and one au chase qui permet de
redémarrer la session elle est de
relancer mon script de boutons ça ça le
gros avantage d'être certain qu'on se
remette dans le métal est sûr qu'à pas
des modifications manivelle qui traînent
dans notre code alors la proche que nous
allons voir aujourd'hui c'est celle d'un
modèle observations répétées qui permet
de prendre en considération l'ensemble
des observations présente comme toi pour
éviter les problèmes qu'on avait
rencontré avec nos analyses séquence
l'idée a pas ramenées l'observation
répéter en fait c'est on va avoir
recours à des modèles tout à fait
classique qu'en l'occurrence aujourd'hui
on va voir une armada de régression
logistique
sauf qu'au lieu de considérer unique par
individu ce que l'on va intégrer dans le
modèle c'est une ligne par individu et
par pas de temps donc on aura plusieurs
observations pour une même personne mais
il faut
mentalement c'est un modèle tout ce qui
est plus classique donc on peut faire
des modèles linéaires des modèles de
régression logistique des modèles de
poisson par contre le fait que nous
allons avoir plusieurs observations pour
une même personne nécessite qu'on prenne
pas en compte dans le modèle en effet
les individus même individu a tendance à
être identique au cours du temps et si
jamais on ne tenait pas compte mais
certaines observations concernent le
même individu
en fait on on va où le problème c'est
que nos coefficients et surtout les
intérêts de confiance qu'on va avoir
on va sur interpréter les résultats et
on risque d'avoir en fait des
intervalles de confiance et où des
pédaleurs qui sont tout petit alors que
dans la réalité c'est pas du tout
significative
on a donc besoin de tenir compte du fait
que certains les certains individus sont
observés plusieurs fois dans les données
et on a deux grandes familles de modèles
auxquels on parle recours dans ces cas
là on peut avoir recours à ce qu'on va
appeler des modèles mixtes
on va rajouter un effet aléatoires donc
j'ai tenté d'intercepter les atours pas
l'individu dans sa version la plus
simple donc soit rajouté un effet les à
thouars par individu dans un modèle
mixte à et les modèles mixer plus tôt on
va dire dans les cas de figure on
s'intéresse vraiment aux effets
individuels il puis l'autre approche
c'est d'avoir des modèles 10 ge donc les
modèles ge sont en outre alternative qui
va pouvoir tenir contre une matrice de
covariance et donc on va aussi tenir
compte de cet effet-là entre les
individus qui sont répétés les modèles
je ne sont peut-être plus souvent
utilisés quand on veut
quand on s'intéresse plutôt à l'effet
populationnelle plus que les faits
individuels je dis ça c'est parce que je
vous avouerai après avoir discuté avec
beaucoup de collègues statisticiens qui
sont beaucoup plus qu'avec moi sur les
bassins de mixer les modèles jeu c'est
pas toujours si évident de salles de
trouver une manière simple ou claire de
dire dans quelqu'un va plutôt
privilégier un modèle knicks ou un
modèle ge retenir en tout cas que les
deux approches sont tout à fait
envisageables lorsque l'on à des données
répéter l'autre élément les modèles
mixtes ils sont plus intéressant
lorsqu'on ils sont aussi utilisés
lorsqu'on a des phénomènes on va dire
des modèles hiérarchisé et vous pouvez
voir notamment sur internet il ya eu je
pense sur les blocs de compte si dans
les tutos met des vidéos sur les modèles
il est rare chizé qui passe aussi par
des modèles mixtes où l'on peut tenir
compte des faits de différent au niveau
c'est-à-dire niveau ménager vos régions
et au niveau pays éventuellement alors
ce qu'on la question c'est donc de
savoir quel type de modèle on va faire
et pour ça je veux vous montrer
je voudrais pas chômé genou rendre sur
le site analyseur parce que je vous ai
préparé sur le site analyseur un petit
document qui vous résume les grands
types de modèles si vous allez dans la
section analyser quel type de modèle
choisir vous avez un grand talent ou
alors qu'il peut être un peu petit je
vais essayer de zoomer hauteur de
tableaux synthétiques qui vous permet de
savoir quel package ok fonctions
utilisées suivant le type de modèle que
l'on veut faire comme vous le voyez on a
trois quatre grandes colonnes vous avez
les modèles de base les modèles que l'on
a vu jusqu'à présent et techniquement ce
serait ce que l'on va utiliser leur
compte utiliser données individuelles
les versions quand on utilise un plan
d'échantillonnage complexe non plan
d'échantillonnage complexe avant les a
vus c'est quand on a à la fois une
pondération
n ont plus d effet de strates hood
kloster non dans les fêtes poster
d'ailleurs c'est une autre manière de
gérer les effets cluster secondes à
l'approché chantier nash complexe soit
éventuellement on peut partir sur des
modèles mix ou ge en contrôlant par
cluster 1 kloster dans une enquête où un
effet de g
du coup belle et l'on considère des
individus même gras pour tendance à se
ressembler c'est la même chose que ce
qu'on a là sur nos modèles observations
répétées
c'est à dire d'un même groupe ont
tendance à se ressembler idron veut dire
qu'on dans le modèle vous avez les
modèles mixtes qui permettent de définir
des effets des effets à des variables
aléatoires et puis vous avez la classe
de famille j'ai eu alors ceci posé pour
choisir un modèle pour une analyse la
deuxième chose qu'on doit se demander
c'est qu'elle est la variable que l'on
souhaite expliquer et suivant le type de
variables que l'on souhaite expliquer on
aura recours à un type de modèle ou un
autre premier cas de figure le plus le
plus simple c'est peu on a une variable
qui continue une variable quantitative
première grande famille de modèles c'est
ce qu'on appelle les modèles linéaires
et si on veut faire un modèle linéaire
et bien c'est le package c'est la
fonction lm de base dans aer qui est
utilisée est pour un modèle mixte line
est un modèle linéaire avec un effet
aléatoire on pourra avoir recours au
parc hlm le cac et le paquet de jeux
plus utilisés pour les modèles mixtes
on a aussi une autre manière
d'appréhender les variables les modèles
les variables continue quelque chose qui
très similaires finalement un modèle
linéaire c'est un modèle gaussien qui se
fait dans la famille dgl m
pour rappel les glm ce sont les modèles
linéaires généralisée mlg et en anglais
general eyes l'aîné amourdom donc vous
avez la famille des modèles j'ai même
qu'on avait déjà une planification
logistique et bien on peut utiliser
famille [ __ ] quand on a une variable
continu l'équivalent pour un plan
d'échantillonnage complexe csv ign qu'on
avait déjà vu du package servait
l'équivalent modèle knicks de manière
classique c'est avec le package l'a4
d'avoir recours à gérer mais alors vous
avez d'autres paquets jack implémente
des modèles miss au taux de variation là
je vous ai vraiment mis en fait les plus
courants et puis vous avez pour faire un
modèle j'ai eu la fonction ge glm
famille négocier du package est opaque
donc une fois qu'on a choisi notre type
de modèle et le type de la m expliquer
ce tableau vous permet d'aller voir à
quel endroit s'orienter petite précision
vous à lessines * pour les modèles je
veux l'autre package qui est pas mal
utilisé
c'est le paquet de ge avec sa fonction
éponyme ge
si je vous privilégiez ge paquet la
fonction ge glm c'est parce que ces
modèles sont mieux prises en compte avec
tiberi deutschen saïdi et ses outils qui
permettent de manipuler les résultats de
modèles autres types de modèles on les a
pas abordé pour le coup qui sont les
hybrides de comptage c'est à dire quand
notre variable d'intérêt c'est un nombre
entier positif
par exemple vous pourriez avoir un
modèle qui s'intéresse en démographie
vous avez des femmes de plus de 50 ans
comptait remis leur vie féconde et vous
vous riez à regarder les facteurs
associés au nombre d'enfants
donc là on est sur une on est sur un
modèle de comptage la nombre
d'occurrences les modèles le comptage on
aura recours à des modèles de poisson le
plus souvent ça se fait du coup avec gl
msv gmg les maires ou ge gm en ayant
recours du koura famille égale poisson
sauf pour svlm puisque là avec les poids
il peut y avoir en fait d'aider des
valeurs qui sont pas tout à fait entière
et on aura au cours duquel famille
coisy poisson qui tue
d'extension la famille de poissons pour
tenir compte éventuellement de poids non
entier petite particularité pour ce type
de modèle là les modèles de poissons en
général on regarde non pas directement
les coefficients mais plutôt leur
exponentielle qui dans le cas d'un
modèle de poissons s'interprète comme un
risque relatif des modèles qui sont un
petit peu et qui m'annonce sur les
modèles binôme i o négatif alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est contre le modèle
de poisson peut être vu comme un cas
particulier d'abonnés le binôme négatif
alors c'est pour ceux qui sont
intéressés
il ya plein littérature disponible sur
les nouveautés le poisson versus les
bonnets le binôme ions négatifs et
sachez que dans ce cas là on aura
recours à l'amp sont un peu plus au fait
il ya deux paramètres
au lieu d'un qui vont être sommes donc
dans la dans la fonction de statistiques
utilisées mais retenez qui sont assez
similaires ils peuvent couvrir en fait
des cas un peu plus large et que
j'aborderai pas là et là vous avez du
coup la fonction glm point et demi du
package miles en basse s'est pas
directement disponibles dans lequel plan
d'échantillonnage complexe mais vous
avez des alternatives disponibles via la
fonction svg l'aiment pour lbj stats ou
svn b2s vers et demi ce qu est l offre 4
vous le propose également avec jmb et à
ma connaissance je suis pas sûr qu'il
est l'implémentation simple des modèles
binet mieux négative en version ge
sachez que on peut aussi parfois
utiliser les modèles de poisson quand on
a une variable binaire de type wii dont
on avait vu jusqu'à présent les modèles
de régression logistique et parfois ce
qu'on voit dans certaines revues lorsque
l'on souhaite exprimer les résultats non
pas en termes de ratio mais plutôt en
termes de risque relatif c'est du coup
le recours avec une variable type oui
non donc en fait c'est un comptage 0 1
on va passer d'un variable à 0 1 et ont
fait du coup on remplace la régression
logistique par un modèle de poissons ce
qui permet dans ce cas là ne pouvoir
interpréter les résultats en termes de
risque relatifs et non pas en termes
d'autres à sion les modèles de poissons
ils ont un intérêt c'est qu'on peut
aussi les utiliser pour modéliser un
ratio une incidence dans ce cas là on
fait ce qu'on veut mobiliser c'est une
tante un modèle d'incidence sur
l'épidémiologie c'est un nombre
d'événements nombre de personnes qui
tombent malades qui va être divisé par
un nombre de personnes années
d'exposition est donc en fait ça se fait
également des modèles de poissons sauf
qu'on va ajouter 1 9 7
donc je vous laisserai regardé sur
internet ici si vous avez besoin un jour
de faire ce type de modèle les recettes
du coup permet d'intégrer dans le modèle
va en fait le début le numéro le
dénominateur et donc du coup on va le
faire avec lionel de poisson ou un
modèle binôme négatif alors ce qu'on
avait le premier modèle qu'on a abordé
ensemble c'était le modèle binaire donc
quand on est variable binaire de type
oui non donc outre les modèles de
poisson le plus courant est le plus
classique c'est ce qu'on appelle un
modèle logistique ou qu'on appelle
encore un modèle profite donc l'intérêt
du modèle probit logistique pad on sait
que l'exponentielle les coefficients
peuvent s'interpréter comme des ânes
ratio c'est pour ça qu'on les utilise de
manière assez fréquentes et vous le
voyez on est dans la famille classique
des modèles glm et donc du coup on aura
recours à gm pour un modèle classique
splm pour les données de les donner une
enquête gmr du package lm 4 ou ge glm du
package est un pack en précisant du coup
qu'on fait un modèle binomiale au coisy
binomiale et au besoin on peut préciser
que c'est de la famille l'audit vous
trouvera aussi dans la littérature des
modèles qui sont les modèles jeep robic
la diff alors qu'ils fournissent des
résultats assez similaire au modèle le
guide sauf que l'exponentielle les
coefficients ne peut pas être
directement interprétées comme des zones
ratio est donc ils sont aussi
la famille binomiale mais avec une
fonction de lien qui est la fonction
probit et puis bien d'autres types de
modèles que je mentionne ici sachez
qu'ils existent le jour où vous pourriez
en avoir besoin vous irez vous
documentez vous former à ces modèles là
c'est modern love bino bio ou la halle
exponentielle les coefficients va
interpréter comme des bananes sur les
chiots ou des risques relatifs alors ils
ont plus de mal à converger et marche
pas aussi bien qu'à modèle low guide
classique mais ils font aussi partie de
la famille des modèles glm et donc voyez
c c'est juste que la fonction de lien
donc c'est la famille binomiale et que
la fonction de lien et la fonction le
gué rythmique nous l'avons vu ça c'est
uniquement dans le cas de figure on a
une variable catégorielles à deux
modalités
la semaine dernière nous avions gardé un
modèle avec valve catégorielles nominal
à trois modalités ou plus
nous avions quatre profils sans qu'ils
soient ordonnés les uns aux autres alors
il ya une petite faute ici en c'est une
régression logistique multi nominale
donc là c'est quand on a une quête d'un
quatrième nominale ou les variables ne
sont pas ordonner les unes par rapport
aux autres
et puis j'aimerais corriger ici est là
c'est la régression logistique
multimodale l'exponentielle d'éco
efficience et après comme d autres ratio
nous l'avions vu dans le cas le plus
classique on aura recours à la fonction
multi nomme du package est nette avec un
plan d'échantillonnage complexe on
pourra avoir recours à esbly multi
d'hommes du package asp ray disc et si
on veut le faire avec un modèle j'ai eu
il ya une implémentation qui fournit par
le package mult ge et qui propose nomme
l'origine voyez j'ai on n'a pas
forcément d'implémentation des modèles
multi multi nos maillots avec plan
en avec avec un effet mixte sachez aussi
que ces modèles multi nommions on les
retrouve aussi dans une caté famille de
modèles beaucoup plus large qui
s'appelle les modèles vgm vous trouverez
dans le chapitre sur l'aviation g6
cordina d'ailleurs des liens vers une
documentation sur ses modèles là donc on
peut aussi les réaliser avec la fonction
vg lmv glm du package vga m family gamme
multi nominal et il y à un package sv y
vgm qui propose une version adaptée au
plan d'échantillonnage complexe pour le
réaliser nous ce qui va nous intéresser
aujourd'hui c'est que on va faire notre
ce qu'on va regarder mais aujourd'hui
c'est notre variable statut qui est
diagnostiquée en soins sous traitement
est sous traitement avec charges
contrôlés donc là c'est une dans la
catégorie reine mais qu'on va pouvoir
considérer comme étant ordinale les
différentes modalités sont les unes au
dessus des autres
et pour ça on pourrait avoir recours à
la régression logistique ordinale alors
cette régression logistique ordinale
elle est implémenté souffert avec
différents package de base vous avez du
coup la fonction vg lm dans le package
vgm qui vous le propose avec du coup
famélique motive et je reviendrai sur
les sur le paramètre parallèle vous avez
aussi d'implémentation dans le package
masquer un des package basware avec la
fonction plr et vous en avez aussi une
implémentation dans le package dit
ordinale qui propose la fonction celle
lorsqu'on a besoin de faire une version
avec un plan d'échantillonnage complexe
on a aussi la plus de choix servais
fournit directement une fonction sv y où
l air mais qui fait que les modèles
ordinaux de base pour plus de choix il
faut aller du côté de sj green
j'élève du package est vive et gm et gm
ou bien avec le package svm isc et sa
fonction sv s'élève donc voyez dès qu'on
veut commencer à faire des modèles un
peu moins courant plus avec une autre
effet ça peut devenir un peu plus
compliqué si on veut avoir un plutôt un
modèle mixte
on a des options qui existe avec le la
fonction clm m
donc clm mixte 1 grosso modo du package
ordinale et si on veut faire une
agression logistique ordinale de manière
j'ai eu
eh bien on a deux implémentations qui
existe là
l'implémentation or de ge du package
j'ai eu le pack mais on a aussi le
package mult ge qui a une version pour
les régressions multi nauviale qui a
aussi une version pour les régressions
ordinale donc nous aujourd'hui ce qu'on
va aborder un c'est la fonction horde
j'ai eu du package ge pâques
enfin qui va nous servir pour
aujourd'hui mais voyez pour choisir ce
modèle là j'ai dû déjà regardé may vary
à d'intérêt ici elle est catégorielle
ordinale puis le type de modèle que je
voulais donc je veux prendre en compte
que mes observations sont répétées donc
je choisis un modèle jeu même si
j'aurais pu prendre aussi l' approche
model mix avec ces mêmes en modèle
ordinale et donc je vais me tourner vers
la fonction or ge du package est opaque
juste pour finir avec le tableau qui est
là mais pour vous dire que vous allez
retrouver aussi à les modèles en analyse
survie avec le fameux modèle de cox
donc on l'a vu qu'ils étaient cox ph
sachez qu'il ya une version sv y hawks
péage qui est fournie par ses revers
vous avez aussi la possibilité d'avoir
un modèle mixte en ayant recours à la
fonction frailty dans cox ph
ou bien il ya d'appeler mentation un
package qui s'appelle coque semi et vous
pouvez utiliser plutôt un approche j'ai
eu avec une option clust
dans son vin immolé donc hawks péage
directement c'est un peu un équivalent
sachez que ce que l'on peut faire
fait relativement un modèle de cox il ya
aussi ce qu'on appelle des modèles étant
discret binomiale c'est le blog
voilà donc voilà donc ce type de modèle
là en fait relève en fait de la famille
des relève en fait de la famille en fait
les glm ce qui du coup on a on retrouve
à la classe de fonction j'ai l'oeil
vigilent lg les verts ge glm les modèles
glmc collection qui sont le mieux
implémenter et vous avez encore deux
types de modèles qui vont resserrer
comme le hac c'est le motif faillite
shy'm qui est implémenté danseurs
virevoltent directement et qui a des
adaptations aussi ailleurs enfin pour
vous mentionniez d'un type de modèle qui
peut exister alors contenus sont des
modèles de comptage me ou le zéro est
sur représentée de manière très
fortement
en fait il ya moyen d'avoir un modèle
qui va distinguer est ce que l'on vit
l'événement donc un peu comme le divx
logistique de type et on va avoir un
premier retrace you et parmi ceux qui
vivent l'événement c'est combien de
filles vont le vivre
donc c'est un peu comme si on combine
est un modèle de poisson avec un beau
avec une régression logistique
on sait pas en fait notre question de
temps quel la probité de vivre
l'événement et si en ville événement
qu'il a profité qu'on le vive plusieurs
fois et donc dans ce cas là en fait on
va récupérer à la fois aux rations la
restauration c'est des modèles i0n
politique poisson modèle ou leur
équivalent à 0 fatigue négative binôme
modin et qui ne sont pas de base
vraiment divine mais vous avez deux
packs et déjà vous avez pc ps c'est elle
qui voulait propose en version de base
et le package csj espace vous en fournit
les versions adaptées au plan
d'échantillonnage
au plan d'échantillonnage complexe voilà
donc c'est juste pour vous montrer un
conte à et encore je n'ai pas abordé
toutes les familles de modèles qui
existent mais j'ai essayé de vous faire
sur un analyseur un peu un tableau
synthétique
même si vous connaissiez pas tous les
modèles l'idée c'est que ça vous plains
d'avoir un point d'entrée et puis après
vous irez vous documenter plus
spécifiquement sur la famille de modèles
qui pourraient correspondre à votre cas
de figure je reviens du coup à notre
question du jour donc ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de regarder les facteurs qui vont
jouer sur le statut dans les soins je
voulais 10,1 et je l'avais on va
regarder ça m'est donc notre variable
d'intérêt c'est donc et states s est
donc on va pouvoir la définir comme une
verrière catégorielles mais clairement
tous nos statuts sont hiérarchisées les
uns par rapport aux autres
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est un modèle
avec tous nos pas de temps et je vais
pouvoir du coup dans cette modélisation
je vais ajouter le temps comme une des
variables explicatives plus à l'âge le
sexe et l'éducation c'est ce qui nous
intéresse petite précision c'est que
malgré tout si vous vous en souvenez 1
on a très peu d'individus observés après
36 mois et la question qui se pose quand
on fait un modèle dans lequel il ya le
temps c'est comment est-ce qu'on va vous
d'élise et le temps une manière de
modéliser le temps c'est de le mettre
sous forme continue je mettrai le moment
variable continu mais ça veut dire que
je suppose que le mois un effet linéaire
qu'il est con que ça évolue de manière
comme une droite
tout au long du temps je pourrai
complexifier ça en mettant le temple ce
temps clarisse qui permet d'avoir des
effets qu'il augmenterait plus
continuerez puis augmentera en fonction
du temps mais j'avoue que même si on
retrouve beaucoup les modélisations du
temps sous forme donc avec temps plus de
temps car et voir tant pis tant qu'art
et plus on occupe dans certains modèles
économiques
pour ma part je ne suis pas un grand fan
en tant que démographe
peut-être parce que je préfère ne pas
anticiper plus que ça sur la forme que
peut prendre le temps
il ya des manières un peu intéressante
avec des plis linéaire mais qui sont
compliqués à mettre en oeuvre est en
fait une approche qui peut être pas mal
pour modéliser le temps c'est de le
modéliser de manière catégorielles c'est
à dire que au lieu d'avoir le temps pour
une variable numérique continue je vais
l'inclure comme un facteur est donc ça
va permettre
du coup d'avoir un effet de permettre à
ce que les effets puisse changer à
toulon à l'ensemble des packs temps donc
c'est plus compliqué à modéliser parce
que là je vais avoir un aux ratios pour
chacun de mes pas de temps donc ça fait
plus éléments a modélisé dans le modèle
alors que si je l'avais mis de manière
linéaire c'est un seul coefficient par
contre ça peut me permettre d'anticiper
que ça peut prendre des formes complexes
dans la relation il pas forcément une
forme linéaire
ceci dit si je fais ça je risque d'avoir
un problème pour les pâtes temps après
36 moscou voyait là j'ai pu beaucoup
d'observation et donc du coup ce que je
vais faire pour mon analyse je ne vais
pas garder les observations après 36
mois je vais garder que les six 36
premiers mois parce que j'aurai après
pas assez d'eau d'observation sur les
derniers pas tant et je vais avoir des
impressions qui deviennent complètement
très incertain et il n'y avait que peu
il y avait peu de d'éléments efficace
enfin l'autre élément c'est que je vais
pas garder le premier mois parce que
vous voyez le premier mois tout le monde
est en mode diagnostic est donc en fait
si je mets le premier mois comme un
droit de comparaison on va pas y voir
grand chose donc là ce que je vais
prendre dans mon modèle jeu
rendre à partir du moins à jusqu au
moins 36 alors on va se placer à la
toute fin du scripps donc nouvelle
section modèle observations répétées et
donc là je vais faire un sous-ensemble
alors donc là c'est nos trajectoires
j'ai transformé qui a trajectoire vise
donc je lis ça c'était 36,1 les
trajectoires de soins 4 octobre il
jusqu'à 36 mois donc je parle de quelle
trajectoire vise et puis je vais retenir
- supérieur à 0 est moins inférieure ou
égale à 36 donc je strictement supérieur
à zéro je démarre à 1 est donc là je
vais avoir déjà un fichier un peu plus
concis ma variable l'intérêt ça va être
quelque chose mais là pour le l'aborder
de manière pour en faire du coup une
pour un modèle ordinale il faut qu'elle
fera côté sous forme de facteurs et de
facteurs ordonné alors je vais ajouter 1
minute et donc je vais créer une
variable que j'appelais clair sur
lectoure j'appelais castétis je vais
l'appeler f
et donc je vais faire appel à la
fonction tout facteur de pierre states
pour rappel genou remet ici qui institue
c'est pour moment codés comme une
variable labellisé je vous remontiez et
si je fais un dauphin voyez c'est pour
moi une variable labellisés et mes
statues sont déjà dans le bon ordre
diagnostic et puis suivi puis sous
traitement puis sous traitement donc là
et contrôle et donc là j'ai aimé ça tue
son bien dans le bon ordre
par contre je vais les mettre sous forme
de facteurs alors si je fais ça je vous
montre lavalas qu'on obtient qui est sfg
quatre niveaux
1 mission juste les uns à côté des
autres et donc du coup en fait ce cette
variable là si je regarde est-ce qu'elle
a ordonné is ordered tu mènes on me dit
non
donc faut que je précise à tout facteur
que ce que je veux c'est obtenir un
facteur ordonnée et donc je rajoute
simplement aux roulottes et garde choo
et si je fais ça vous voyez que isolde
2,7 et 36 cas status bochum et si je
regarde la variable elle se présente un
tout petit peu différemment
voyez ici les niveaux sont présentés
avec des inférieures ou est inférieure à
ses juste une manière de dire que là
mais niveau sont ordonnés les uns par
rapport aux autres qui est un peu
l'hypothèse d'un modèle
qu'un peu l'hypothèse d'un modèle d'une
régression logistique ordinale ce que je
vais également faire je vais faire une
version factoriser du mois donc non ça
va être tout factor demain puisque je
voulais dit je veux vouloir intégrer le
mois de manière deux manières
catégorielles et puis je vais aussi tant
qu'on lit fr des facteurs pour mais
variable explicative que je voulais dans
le modèle donc une manière de conseil en
fait de conserver en fait les versions
d'origine genre fait juste des variables
et je remets un f majuscule ce qui
permet de me rappeler qu' il s'agit de
la version d'une version facteur de mais
variable catégorielles donc saxer
ducation et âge donc une fois que j'ai
ce si j'ai un objet c'est et 36 avec du
coup les éléments et g ces différentes
variables une variable ordonnée et
différents facteurs qui sont présents on
va s'occuper calculé le modèle et vous
allez le voir finalement c'est pas le
plus compliqué donc je vais charger j'ai
eu le pack puisque nous allons avoir
recours à la fonction horde
j'ai eu 2 g je veux pas qu je peux
sortir l'aide de la fonction c'est
toujours utile alors comme la plupart
des fonctions 1
on va avoir une formule qui va être du
coup qui va nous indiquer à nos
le modèle que l'on veut ce qui est
important c'est de fournir à paramètre
id donc il va être un identifiant des
individus qui va permettre d'identifier
ceux qui appartiennent les observations
qui appartiennent à la même personne et
nous elle s'appelle également idée
d'aller dans notre fichier et puis on a
comme souvent un objet qui s'appelle
date avons donc notre modèle donc j'ai
appelé donc là c'est la plaie mode td
comme dans l'exemple
notre modèle 1 ses ordres ge ge indique
la formule du modèle donc mon modèle si
je vais expliquer ce qui m'a tu es là
c'est donc pierre states mais qui se
font deux facteurs en fonction du sexe
de l'âge de l'éducation du niveau
d'éducation t il important que je
rajoute dans le modèle le temps ici qui
va être modélisée du coup sous forme du
mois et qui va être souvent le facteur
les données data à cct 36 objets
deviennent créé il faut que je précise
la variable que les identifiants qui
vont permettre de le savoir en fait
quels sont les observations qui
appartiennent au même individu pour
justement en tenir compte c'est tout
l'objet passer par un modèle ge et ça
c'est donc cct 36 idée je passe le
vecteur avec les identifiants
alors ça met un petit peu temps de
calcul
là ça va encore sachez que sur certains
modèles des modèles des gros modèles g
ou des monnaies le mix
ça peut parfois prendre plusieurs heures
de calcul
soyez vigilants sur ces modèles là c'est
pas ça peut être parfois très très long
à converger là avec orgue ge et vu la
taille de l'échantillon on arrive encore
avoir un modèle qui se calculent assez
vite
alors voyons voir le modèle qu'on
obtient qui s'appelle mode td je vais
ouvrir ici est donc là vous avez les
différents coefficient du modèle voilà
qui nous sont affichés à l'écran
donc on a trois intercepte qui
apparaissent en premier
en fait c'est intercepte la traduisent
le fait de passer de chacune des étapes
à l'autre c'est à dire ils vont ils ont
capturé grosseur de la probité de passer
de diagnostiquer à en soins le deuxième
de suivi devant soins à deux traitements
et le quatrième de traitement au
contrôle donc c'est 3 intercepte en fait
qu'ils sont cons passage de l'un à
l'autre les particularités d'un modèle
de régression logistique ordinale c'est
que là en fait c'est ce qu'on en fait
l'hypothèse sous jacente c'est que vous
retrouvez dans d'autres fonctions qu'on
appelle par là elle sait qu'ils ont on
considère que l'effet du sexe est le
même quand on compare canton qu'on en
fait à chaque quine des à chacun des
éléments on peut avoir une nouvelle plus
complexes ou de leur dîner qui ont gardé
si l'effet d'être en soins plutôt que
hors soins est différent que l'effet
d'être sous traitement plutôt que pas
sous traitement met donc dans ce cas là
ça veut dire qu'on va multiplier les
coefficients lundi la blackhat modalités
on aurait eu trois jeux de produits
fission une autre et du coup il faut
avoir assez d'observation du coup pour
arriver à
à ce que le modèle convergent l'autre
option c'est de se dire que l'effet du
sexe est le même pour chacune des étapes
de ma variable ordinale mais que le sexe
joue de la même manière sur le fait
d'être en soins plutôt qu'on peut en
soins sur le fait d'être en traitement
plutôt que pas sous traitement et sur le
fait des contrôles est plutôt compact
contrôler et donc avec angelo on est sûr
sur le modèle de ses modèles de base ont
beaucoup de fonctions qui font des mre
lordinot donc parmi celles que je vous
ai présenté un ici pour les modèles
ordinaux comme polaire ou hors jeu en
fait sont sur cette idée de parallèle on
si vous passez par la fonction vg lm
voyez ici un paramètre pas bonne elle
qui permet de choisir si on veut des
coefficients parallèle c'est là qu'ils
sont les mêmes sur toutes les
comparaisons ou si au contraire on veut
des coefficients on veut trois jeux de
coefficients et si vous passez par clm
là vous avez la possibilité de choisir
que certaines variables serait en
coefficient pareil c'est à dire les
mêmes pour toutes les transitions et
d'autres pour lesquels on calculerait
des transitions différentes demandes et
aux ratios différents ce qui permet de
réduire aussi le nombre de coefficient
là je raison vraiment la version la plus
simple est l'hypothèse la plus simple
c'est vraiment cette hypothèse de parra
lité des zones ratio c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on compare lorsque je compare le
passage de 6 g 4 niveaux ap cdc que je
vais c'est que les faits des preuves en
dessous de 1 versus au dessus de b
l'effet du sexe sur cette différence là
est la même que l'effet du sexe sur le
fait d'être en dessous de ces versus au
dessus de ces pour simplifier
si vous en voulez plus d'informations
sur ces enjeux là si vous allez regarder
dans le chapitre régression logistique
et vous allez surpression logistique
ordinale
à gien vous avez secours
il ya ce courant fait qu'ils vous aient
indiqué qu'une bonne introduction en
français à la régression de le style
polito mialhe colis tomic donc les
modèles dits ordinaux ils reviennent
alors il présente et j'aime ça ce
document d'une vingtaine de pages
revient sur la question des le guide a
déjà sondé le git cumulatif voilà vous
aurez plus plus d'éléments pour bien
comprendre les différentes variations au
tour à tour alors je vois une question
qui nous est posée qui est que faut-il
faire si on ne dispose pas
d'informations sur l'étang de transition
alors je ne sais pas exactement ce que
vous voulez dire par là là dans le
modèle on n'a pas d'informations sur
l'étang de transition ce qu'on a cédé
points on sait que à cette date là
l'individu est dans ce statut là dans
mon jeu de données si l'individu est
marqué comme étant en soins am3 et pas
en soin à m 2 je ne sais pas à quel
moment a lieu la transition là nous ne
savons pas si l'individu est rentré dans
les soins au bout de deux mois et demi
ou au bout de 2,9 mois au bout de 2,1 un
mois on ne connaît point d'observation
mais sur ce type de modèle là c'est
problématique lorsqu'on regarde c'est la
probabilité d'être dans un état ce qu'on
attend seul dans le modèle quelques je
me présente là j'ai mon statut qui n'a
aucune autre cas documentés à chaque
point de temps ce que je modélise sait
quels sont les facteurs d'être dans un
état donné à un certain moment du temps
je ne lis pas le fait de vivre un
événement un moment donné ce que ça
c'est ce qu'on avait fait plutôt avec
les modèles de régression logistique
il est possible d'avoir aussi des
modèles observations répétées amour mais
dans ce cas là un lieu d'avoir une
variable statut
variable de à ce moment du temps il
s'est passé un événement et je
mobiliserai dans ce cas plutôt la
probabilité de vivre un événement donné
un certain moment de temps mais là ce
que je n'ai modéliser c'est pas le fait
de vivre un événement à un moment donné
la sq ont modélisé le fait d'être dans
un état donné à un moment du temps
n'oubliez pas cette distinction
fondamentale entre événements et statues
ou événements et et à un événement c'est
ce qui produit un changement d'état donc
un événement a lieu à un moment dans le
temps et un état il se maintient entre
deux événements
donc ça cette distinction fondamentale c
est tout aussi importante que la
distinction que l'on va avoir entre eux
flux et stocks
c'est vraiment important de bien l'avoir
en tête donc là je veux tel que j'ai
fait parce que jenny ce que j'ai
modéliser mme amon autres comme ce ne
sont pas des événements ce sont des
états 1 c'est la probabilité d'être dans
un état donné à chaque moment du temps
alors comme la variable et plus
précisément ce que j'ai mobilisé
finalement c'est une c1 et a ordonné
donc on peut le voir comme une variable
continu et non ce que va le donner mon
modèle c'est eux c'est ce qui va faire
varier mon avancée sur mon échec et on
va aller voir un peu plus loin lorsqu'on
allait voir du coup les coefficients
maintenant on a un modèle mais là j'ai
des coefficients et avant qu'on aime
regarder nos coefficient est qu'on aille
un peu plus loin on va voir comment est
ce qu'on fait pour récupérer les
coefficients les évalue les intervalles
de confiance alors
on va avoir les différentes techniques
qu'on peut utiliser pour récupérer des
intervalles de confiance
déjà première chose quand on a un modèle
on peut toujours regarder le rendu du
modèle et puis fait un se marient sur le
modèle normalement pour tous les modèles
vous avez une fonction somalie donc ça
ça va vous présenter les informations de
différentes manières voilà là vous avez
donc si je fais beaucoup aidé et je le
remonte de 6 dans la console voyez il me
présente en fait un centre de formation
de base plus nos différents coefficient
si je fais ce mallery de mode des
départs dont il va nous présenter les
résultats y voit il ya un grand tableau
où l'ag mais coefficient un écart-type
autour du coefficient une valeur pour
ward et la paix valeur donc là on voit
que j'ai directement les principales
informations par contre au moment gpad
intervalle de confiance qui me sont
affichés dans les faits si on
s'intéresse
si on veut pouvoir récupérer les
informations savoir qu' il ya commença
sa fille jean la ponceuse et qu'est-ce
qui est renvoyée proprement dit donc en
fait je vais je faire un objet s
d'accord qui va renvoyer ce que me
renvoie se marie si je fais print de sc
ce qui me passe quand je tape pour
générale juste 16 ans la console on a
cette mise en forme qui est là ce qu'on
peut aller regarder
c'est plus précisément si je fais view
deux aces - str de la saison la
structure de l'objet qu'il est renvoyé
en fait se marient ici
me renvoie un objet un peu plus
compliqué d'accord qui est une liste
avec plusieurs éléments ce que je vois
c'est que j'ai une première liste avec
un premier élément qui s'appelle mine où
j'ai les estiment les coefficients
estimate les écarts type world ep je le
vois que j'ai le tableau de corrélation
d'autres éléments mais l'information la
plus intéressante ici ça serait mieux en
général on passe pas trop parce main lui
parce que ça affiche quelque chose à
l'écran c'est pas forcément ce qui est
plus pratique donc les techniques
usuelles pour essayer d'avoir un beau
tableau de nos coefficient la première
dire c'est une fête lively jti se
marient et ont fait un petit vélo les
goûts les chaînes à partir du modèle
problème ça ne marche pas donc là on est
face à un modèle un outil bien webmotion
ne fonctionne pas alors là pour le coup
c'est quelque chose de connu
parfois il peut y avoir d'autres erreurs
d'antibes ian donc on va voir les autres
approches rares petites précisions ici
si je ne fais rien et que je garde ça je
vais fait si je fais cnit
je ne pourrais pas le bout parce que
j'ai une erreur et quand il ya une
erreur par défaut le document ne va pas
jusqu'au fond si je veux dire c'est pas
grave même si une erreur continue à
faire le rapport il faut que je précise
et ringard ou dans les options ici une
autre deuxième approche siggi this
marine ne marche pas déjà on va vérifier
est ce qu'on peut faire
la fonction boom d'accord donc je vous
en avais parlé vous avez goom avec sa
fonction taille 10
et là il se trouve qu'il n'ya pas de
méthode taille 10 pour les objets de
type ge mais ceux qui le gèrent envoyée
on peut aller regarder sinon du côté de
la librairie par la méthode d'accord qui
fournit une fonction modèle par la
metteuse est et on voit que maintenant
aujourd'hui le modèle parameters ne
marche pas encore prêt obligé de s e ce
qui se passe et parfois on aurait une
fonction n'aura pas de fonctions tahiti
dans boom mais on en aura une qui existe
dans parameters et on pourra du coup
récupérer un bout-à-bout des résultats
exploitables
sachez que ce qui peut être aussi
utilisé et qui utilise du coup les deux
par défaut c'est la baby boom
elles peuvent alors vous me pose c'est
une je la connais bien puisque c'est moi
qui ai développé ce package en fait ça
ça va passer par boom ou par parameters
par défaut donc ça vérifie les deux
directement et puis ça améliore le
tableau de résultats et c'est utilisé
notamment par guy thys mari pour tibéri
création repose sur brummel pause ou
bien par gégé coeff modèle qu'on est il
pour les coefficients pour mettre en
forme récupérer les étiquettes vous
rajoutez les vagues d'été de référence
est donc dans ce cas là c'est la
fonction time d'hypnose place jean-louis
passe mon modèle et là ça ne marche pas
donc en fait j'ai pas tiger de base
donc on n'a pas de taïder nombre houle
on n'a pas de taille des remparts a
method brevet de peur j'aurais pu ici de
jongler avec les deux mais y'a rien
alors dit ya une petite astuce que je
vous donne
j'ai écrit pour ma part j'ai un package
qui savent qui est pas sur croquis et un
truc un peu général mais qui s'appelle
jl subtil et je vais vous donner
l'astuce
alors j l'utilisé pas où on en parle 1
plusieurs fois sur l'analyse r après on
peut aussi on n'est pas toujours obligé
d'installer parfois certains trous peut
avoir des problèmes pour ça
j'ai lu 10 si c'est le cas il ya une
autre astuce qui consiste à télécharger
que la fonction qui nous intéresse on va
aller là vous êtes sur la page aux jmj
utilisent on va aller sur les pages
r et je vais vous montrer juste la
fonction de taille du modèle
en fait j'ai essayé de faire des gardes
c'est un tas leader un peu génériques
alors ce qu'on voudrait c'est le code
gros nous si on récupère cette url là je
vous mets vraisemblance cryptage comme
ça vous l'aurez est donc en fait si vous
faites source url
alors j'ai oublié les guillemets parce
que ça fait si vous n'avez pas installé
des package ils l'utilisent c'est pas
grave vous faites juste ça ça va juste
chargé le code de la fonction taille du
modèle qui m'intéresse ici donc taille
du modèle c'est une fonction très
générique c'est au tour de taille
d'heure un peu de secours
ça marche pas tout le temps mais il ya
tout un ensemble de cas où on n'a pas de
taille d'heure pour un modèle qui est
dans parameters drum metagame modèle
arrive quand même à s'y retrouver et il
est attaqué là en fait il se trouve que
ça ne marche pas pour ceux qui à présent
parce que je vous ai pris un exemple
volontairement c'est assez rare mais au
fil des solutions avant d'enfin je vous
amène sa afin de vous montrer comment on
va faire les choses par nous mêmes donc
retenu pour la plupart des modèles creux
majorité le modèle ça ça marche direct
et on en général taille du modèle
parameters qui va fonctionner dans
certains cas aux pierrots plus passer
par tahiti monnaie si ça ne marche
toujours pas ce qu'on peut regarder dans
le monde ces deux choses c'est la faux
culs la première fonction c'est coeff
d'accord normalement pour la plupart des
modèles
on peut appliquer la méthode cauet f qui
va extraire les coefficients quasiment
tous les modèles ont implémenté et en
fait voyez ici ça ne marche pas donc
coeff normalement pas mais récupère
les coefficients du modèle 'confiant'
suis appliqué sur un modèle permet de
récupérer les intervalles de confiance
est en fête qui se passe c'est que pour
ce type de modèle là ça n'a pas été
implémentées donc je vous montre
normalement ce qu'on vérifie un par un
si ça marche pas on passe à l'étape
d'après si ça marche pas on passe à
temps après et vous allez voir on va
quand même toujours s'en sortir mais
s'est dans certains cas où quand on
commence à faire des choses à une faut
que ça soit un modèle ge et puis ça et
puis ça et puis ça on n'a pas forcément
de choses toujours clé en main à
disposition même si le retard se
rattrape de manière importante
alors comment est ce qu'on va faire on
l'a vu je peux récupérer le résultat de
ce mari dans un objet d'accord donc là
si je regarde bien j'ai un objet s
et dans le cas de ce type de modèle je
vois que j'ai un sous-ensemble milky un
tableau où j'ai bien mais coefficient
m'aider et quartier pdp valeurs déjà une
grosse partie du travail est déjà fait
encore drew mon résultat
dans ce qui m'intéresse c'est finalement
le premier élément qu'ils ont appelée
mines
si julio bien j'ai un premier data frais
ce qu'on voit c'est que j'ai quatre
colonnes estimé sané ce world pis mais
quand je vois à l'écran il ya quelque
chose en plus ici qui sont en fait les
noms des coefficients ils sont biens
stockés mais en fait ils sont stockés
dans le cas présent comme nom de lire
on n'est pas comme une variable en tant
que tel donc ça je vais peut les
récupérer avec la fonction bruins donc
je rajouter une nouvelle colonne avant
de gérer ce que j'appelais thème qui va
contenir le nom des terres qui pour moi
est stockée en ont
ligne donc j'applique la fonction ronen
ce que j'applique à mon objet reste si
je regarde maintenant mon objet rays
voyez là j'ai les noms mais ici j'ai
bien une variable qui va contenir la
formation en tant que tel et qui va être
utilisable les valeurs world et les
estimations qu'est ce qui manque ce qui
manque à ce stade là c'est des
intervalles de confiance
sauf que malgré tout les paies valeurs
qui me sont déjà fourni donc ça c'est
bien j'aurai pas calculer j'ai le test
de one
j'ai un écart-type déjà qui est pour le
coup si on veut plus d'informations
d'ailleurs qu'on trouvera dans le lait 2
j'ai eu est ce on devrait avoir le type
d information sur les différents
éléments du résultat dans l'aide
on peut aller chercher ce qui est à
retenir en tout cas pour nous c'est que
gère des quartiers qui va être
utilisable donc normalement un
intervalle de confiance c'est
l'estimation plus ou moins l'écart type
x notre fameux à 96 alors le fameux à 96
que certains connaissent peut-être c'est
quand on est sur la loi normale c'est
qu'en fait si on prend la distribution
normale et qu'on va regarder un
intervalle de confiance à 95 %
c'est-à-dire qu'on veut avoir deux
mi-temps sont d'un côté 2% de l'autre
côté on va le centre est et donc du coup
on va regarder la distribution de la loi
normale sont très réduites et ensuite
j'aurai plus qu'à appliquer qui
correspond au cas où les quartiers
bourrin et là j'ai une variance piqué
que des écarts types qui sont calculés
donc j'aurai plus qu'à l'appliquer
en fait le 1,96 quand on veut le
récupérer en tant que tel ça peut se
faire de manière plus précise on se
multiplent là
celui qu'on utilise pour les intervalle
de confiance à 95 %
en fait on peut récupérer la
distribution de la loi normale ça
s'appelle qu'une norme la fonction il
faut dire où est ce qu'on veut se
positionner
alors pour le coup sur internet de
confiance à 95 % 1 en fait on veut se
mettre à 97 5%
parce que je laisse 2 5% sur la droite
et parce qu'on aura la symétrie de
l'autre côté
donc en fait je le veux pour 97 5 et ça
voyez ça me renvoie le 1 95 99 64 donc
ses 97 5 ou si vous voulez un truc plus
générique on peut poser donc c'est alpha
égale points 95 et donc la valeur qu'on
va chercher c'est un plus alpha le tout
divisé par le pur alors que je te plus
générique
donc ça fait 1 +0 95 / deux semaines
donnera le 97 5 et donc ça je vais
sauvegarde et ça je vais l'appeler meute
sam est mon élément de multiplication et
donc pour calculer mon intervalle de
confiance dans sa version la plus simple
un et ben rays of law
ça va être 13 estiment ex ou moins
me lutz fois rays san esprits et
l'intervalle de confiance
oh ça va être la même chose mais avec
inclus
donc là je fais vraiment une version
simplifiée
si jamais le mot dire que vous avez vous
fournissez un terrain de confiance vous
utiliser directement ce qui vous
fournissez le mieux mais la voyez on
peut quand même arriver assez facilement
car calculée par nous même intervalle de
confiance donc quand vous avez un doute
sur des modèles pour que c'est pas bien
généralement aller chercher sur google
plus tôt en anglais sur internet mais si
vous avez un doute je vais sur le site
est ainsi qu un jour on déjà parler de r
ci.org rse eu qu'à voyager et si je fais
horde
j'ai eu le nom modèle confidence in town
il ya probablement des chances en vous
le redis ce quelque part donc horde ge
eux c'est du package
j'ai le pack parfois en cherchant ou au
dessous un parfois en cherchant dans les
premiers résultats vous allez trouver
une telle question où vous allez sur
stack overflow ou sur d'autres sites et
vous pouvez trouver en fait en anglais
d'aider des ressources
voilà il se trouve que l'astuce un
voleur est directement donné sur
l'analyseur et de manière générale
retenait que si jamais vous avez l'écart
type est votre valeur ou en général il
est possible de recalculer manuellement
des intervalles de confiance
ce qu'il faut surtout ne pas hésiter à
aller chercher ou parfois vous prenez un
course aux orgueilleux en fait je prends
sur des tutoriels de horde ge j'ai
trouvé l'astuce
retenez que voilà faut être en capacité
d'aller chercher l'information lorsque
vous ne savez pas trop
alors là j'ai misé intervalle de
confiance et mékong et les éléments qui
sont pour le moment en qui sont de
manière classique moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est pas les valeurs sont très ou
plutôt les ratios et donc dans ce cas là
on a juste besoin de passer à l'exposant
donc ce que je vais faire rêver steam et
ça va être et xp derez estimate je fais
la même chose pour les intervalles de
confiance donc j'applique exponentielle
sur chacune de valeur pour pouvoir
présenter plus tôt
les ratios j'exécute tout ça et j'aime
du coup maintenant mais intervalle de
confiance et mes éléments pour faire un
tableau ce que j'aimerais maintenant
c'est un petit tableau pour présenter
mes résultats
alors je vais faire quelque chose qui
soit peut-être un peu plus facile à lire
donc je vais faire un tableau je vais
partir de rêve j'ai pas besoin de tout
conserver un donc d'une part je m en
forme certains éléments donc mes valeurs
j'aimerais les présenter donc on a vu il
ya la fonction la fonction number qui
doit la librairie ce qui donne un qui
permet de mettre en forme dénombre donc
estimate savez je repars d'estimé et je
vais indiquer accueilli 6.01 mais mise
en forme
une mise en forme femmes jeu pour p
l'épée valeurs je peux utiliser la
fonction paie value de skieuses qui met
en forme d'épée verts et qui va pouvoir
m
donc je vais simplement dire moi j'ai
utilisé tel quel on paie value de paix
et puis je te faire une rumeur que
j'appelais série d'accords j'utilise
past 0 qui me permet de coller ensemble
des chaînes de caractères et donc j'ai
fait un truc un peu jolie je mette un
crochet ensuite je vais alors que ce
soit puisse jamais être sur plusieurs
lignes
donc ensuite ce que je vais mettre c'est
l'interface bas donc c'est confus
nouveau incurie ci alors a bondi à une
seule des six malin pour gagner un peu d
espace puis je vais mettre un tiret puis
je mettre un intervalle de confiance aux
arrondis aussi et après je vais ajouter
un crochet ferment ce que je vais faire
je vais pas tout garder donc je vais
faire qu'est-ce que je me affiché je
veux du coup affiché terme estimé c.é
ep je vais les renommer en même temps
donc c'est assez variable égal thème aux
ratios qui est égal à estimer death 95
alors j'ai appelé à 95 pour son celi est
guérissable
et puis je vais faire une variable je
vais à pied les valeurs d'envoyer si je
fais ça hein qu'est ce que j'ai jusqu'à
présent donc mieux tes j'ai transformé
un ensemble d'éléments
et puis j'ai retenu que certains
éléments et donc du coup je récupère ce
que j'ai ce qui vous ce qui se passe
c'est que j'ai toujours alors
pour ça soit plus facile à lire je vais
appeler la fonction câble de cnidaires
minitel câble j'ai bien tous les
éléments qui sont là par contre
effectivement il ya encore des les noms
de colonnes qui traîne donc je vais
demander un câble pam est affiché avec
lyon nîmes c'est galles-france pour pas
les afficher et éventuellement je vais
changer les alignements alors je peux
faire aligne alors la fonction à la
ligne du cou dans le calme je met une
lettre l'efs gauche
wright droite c'est center chacune des
colonnes donc la première variable des
soins n'est ni à gauche les zones ratio
à droite les intervalles de confiance
entrées et les vraies valeurs à droite
ça me permet de contrôler du coup mais
un alignement d'envoyer larmes
je commence à avoir un tableau peu près
propre avec tous mes résultats
un méandre as you may intervalle de
confiance à 95 % et mais p valeur
éventuellement je pourrais me dire que
je supprimerai brève bien j'ai pas
forcément besoin de garder de garder les
trois premières lignes à 1 c'est l'oubli
à l'inter
donc je vais rajouter abandonné 1 filter
et la question c'est comment on pourra
trouver comment on reconnaît du coup
là où il ya marqué un terme en fait vous
avez les fonctions de la députation tech
sont des fonctions qui vous paraissent
terre s'en charger automatiquement avec
l'hôtel diverses nous est notamment
esther détecte d'accord si je fais
esther détecte et que je vais détecté
sur la colonne terme
je cherche un ter d'accord alors là j'ai
mis dans un filter maintenant les pow
wow j'en veux pas deep la guerre fit ce
que j'ai pas de filtrer à parler parce
que je sais pourquoi
c'est parce que terme n'existe plus il a
été renommé en variable
jamais avant mon select avant que leur
noble et variables d'accord donc si je
fais ça voyez la détecter donc ça prend
terme et sa recherche
qu'est ce qu'on y trouve intègre alors
là j'ai du coup les trois variables
d'intercepter parce que je me sens
inverse nous pour inverser un résultat
on n'oublie jamais que pour deux
conditions logiques linverse obtient
avec le point d'exclamation classé
devant elle a du coup je garde ce on n'a
pas détecté
on n'a pas trouvé le texte interne dans
le nom de la variable bien fait et pas
une variable c'est plutôt un facteur
plusieurs ici je voulais faire les
choses plus proprement jr renault mais
aussi manuellement pour mettre des
étiquettes plus propre comme c'est c'est
le calmy rey dans la version qui est en
ligne
alors une fois que j'ai ça on peut on
faire un graphique alors ça peut se
faire assez facilement
gg coeff modèle ne marche pas
directement si j'essaye avec le deep
ravi j'ai cali ainsi je prends
gg coeff modèle qu'on avait vu jusqu'à
présent et que je m'appuie mines ltd
là ça ne marche pas parce qu'il n'arrive
pas du coup à placer taille dit claude
closse et à faire l'élément par contre
on peut avoir recours
vu que nous on a déjà fait le travail de
mettre en forme sous un tableau avec du
coup des nombreux correspondants à peu
près on pourrait utiliser un
sous-ensemble en fait si vous regardez
l'aide de gégé coeff modèle en fait vous
avez vous avez une fonction s'appelle gg
coeff pelote 1 donc en fait ce que font
les gg colette modèle il va chercher les
informations mais en forme les données
après passes le tout âge et j'ai collé
flotte et en fait on peut appeler du
coup directement gg cocotte avec un
tableau de résultats de type modèle un
peu comme l'objet reste convient de
faire et donc je peux essayer
d'appliquer gkf pelote à mon tableau
rêve alors peut-être qu'il faut un que
je précise quelques éléments et on va à
lyon voir voyons voir qu'est ce qui peut
poser près par défaut 1 il va chercher
en x une bague colonnes estimé malcom
j'ai bien clé steam et sauf que le nom
que jamais en vertical
c'est pas une colonne label par contre
j'ai une colonne terme donc il faut que
je lui précise que ans y est ce qu'on va
maps et c'est plutôt la variable thème
que j'ai pas de variables la belle dans
les dents dans l'élément la ji là on
commence avec déjà un petit peu mieux
mais il y a façades fouroux d'accord qui
par défaut il va séparer les variables
en cherche une colonne s'appelle un
label or moi j'ai pas de colonne var
label
et du coup il faut que je désactive
comment un je crois que facet frau on va
vont peut lui passer simplement à l'aide
alors si je fais face c'est le légal
nulle
voilà ce que j'aime rien qui indique en
fait où est où et vous est la variable
et je vais rajouter un dernier élément
[Musique]
enfin cette fois ils deviennent nul
j'ai pas du coup de deux variables
si j'avais recoder à récréer les notions
de variables j'ai indiqué exponentielle
voilà exponentielle égale tous pour dire
que l'échelle part qu'on doit être voilà
mis en forme exponentielle on y verra
beaucoup mieux les effets et
éventuellement je vais rajouter mon
petit filtre pour retirer je vais
retirer mais intercepte je récupère cet
élément là et puis je vais augmenter la
taille du graphique
alors stop figure size et ont fait
l'essai du bape au poker j'écoute
réduire la hauteur fini à 8 6 voilà donc
là c'est le graphique qu'on obtient
et vous voulez on peut faire une version
un peu plus un peu plus belle si vous
retournez sur le site analyse r si on va
dans une trajectoire de soins et sur
notre modèle à observations répétées
vous retrouver les mêmes éléments 1 mais
là on a pris le temps de recoder du coup
les différentes allées terme autre chose
de plus efficace et puis rajouter les
noms de variables voilà est donc là vous
obtenez le le même graphique mais avec
un peu de la couleur qui permet d'y voir
un peu plus clair
on voit deux choses d'une part voyez on
a modélisé les faits temps donc ça veut
dire que toutes choses égales par
ailleurs et en fait là on est aux
modalités de référence c'est-à-dire en
prime pour les pour les hommes jeunes
primaire d'accord ça c'est l'évolution
temporelle l'a en partie principe que
l'évolution temporelle était grosso modo
la même pour tout le monde
sinon il faudrait rajouter les termes
d'interaction dans le modèle pour
regarder des coefficients du temps en
fonction du sexe et là du coup peut-être
qu'on resterait pas surinterpréter
gorille années qu'on ferait une
modélisation un petit peu différente
mais voyez ça ça veut dire que au cours
du temps il ya les autres as you qui
sont par rapport à m
1 ça vous montre votre évolution par
rapport à ma donc là on a mobilisé
l'effet global du temps qui veut dire
que les gens avant la cascade de soins
globalement au cours du temps et de
manière assez important mais l'intérêt
dans le modèle telle qu'on la modéliser
cette voie vraiment un effet global 1 du
sexe de l'âge et l'éducation
et là on voit que les femmes de manière
globale vos avances sont plus souvent à
un état avancé la casquette de soins que
les hommes que les 30 50 et 60 est plus
aussi plus avancé dans la casquette de
soins que les jeunes et que ce conte au
niveau secondaire et supérieur sont plus
avancés un respect de soins un clown
niveau primaire donc là en fait tu m'as
pris peut donner et on a réussi
la mode elle arrête finalement la seule
condition pour le sexe l'âge et
éducation qui synthétise de manière
assez à ce qu'on voyait déjà sur les
autres approches
maintenant ce qui pourrait être fait
suivant comment vous posez la question
c'est éventuellement d'explorer des
effets d'interaction et notamment si à
l'anc peut-être modéliser le temps
différemment pour les hommes et pour les
femmes pour voir si on observe d'autres
éléments
les voiliers on a aussi la possibilité 1
sans passer par des modèles sur vie de
pouvoir passer par des modèles plus
classiques observations répétées
ça nécessite du coup de passer sur la
gamme des modèles mix ou des modèles ge
dont on peut s'en sortir on peut
modéliser sur des modèles observations
répétées souhaite variable de statut
soit modéliser une variable de souhaits
de variables de statut soit une variable
d'événements ça sera pas la même chose à
interpréter et ça vous permettra
d'annoncer je vais pas forcément creuser
beaucoup plus sur la question des
brevets de l'observation répéter on sait
juste pour vous monter que c'est une
manière aussi pouvoir aborder la
question et suivant comme on se
questionne souvent qu'on me remettre les
éléments en place on va pouvoir se poser
la question
on va pouvoir faire des modèles plus ou
moins complexes et jongler sur les
effets d'un terreau actions et les
manières de modéliser les temps et là il
ya énormément de da proches qui sont
différentes et complémentaires avant de
vous quitter
pour cet été quelques mots rapides sur
un modèle survie multi et alors c'est un
petit peu long à à calculer donc je vais
juste plutôt présenté un rapidement ce
que vous retrouverez dans le chapitre
d'analyseurs l'intérêt des modèles de
survie multi-etats c'est toute une gamme
de modèles qui permettent de prendre en
compte des transitions d'un état à un
autre à différents moments du temps une
des extensions possibles pour les
modèles de série multi états sont
l'extension msm qui repose sur des
modèles de markov et qui peut prendre du
coup en plus des coûts variables dans le
modèle la première chose ça va être de
modéliser alors il ya une petite
contrainte
nick il faut nous notre var hier sur la
côte est sous forme numérique
là c'est assez facile on a fait une
petite transformation où on va co d1 le
premier étage deuxième étape 3 le
troisième est à 4 le quatrième état mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on va
ensuite pouvoir dire quels sont les
transitions possible dans les modèles
multi étapes on peut en fait créer un
schéma n'en peu complexe qui dit les
transitions possible à revenu dans notre
cash le schéma mais c'est assez simple
c'est on peut passer des diagnostics et
a suivi de suivi à ce traitement est
sous traitement à infection control et
et puis ça aille dans le sens inverse on
a vu on a un cas qui est vraiment simple
mais vous pouvez avoir des phénomènes de
transition plus complexes et distinguer
des états auxquels on va quitter mais
jamais revenir et des transitions
inverse
dans tous les cas ce qui va être
important ça va être
on va faire un tableau qui va dire les
transitions possible
là en l'occurrence je vais dire pour
passer l'étape 1 à l'étal 2 quand on est
on est à deux on peut revenir à un passé
à l'état 3 quand on en est à trois on
peut repasser à l'étape 2 ou pas c est à
4 et quand on est à 1 4 on peut
seulement repasser à l'état 1 ça
correspond aux flèches qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure la fonction c'était cbl points
mais ça vous dit les transitions
observée dans jeux de données et la
manche donné on voit des gens qui
passent de l'état 1 1 et à 3 par exemple
des gens qui passent de l'état 1 l'état
4 mais en fait ce n'est pas dérangeant
sinon modèle on n'a pas prévu de
transition de 1 à 3 puisqu'en fait pour
nous une transition de 1 à 3 c
implicitement un passage de 1 vers
depuis 2,2 vers 3 est en fait du coup
msm sera identifié des transitions qui
ne sont pas directs et qui passe par un
état intermédiaire et en tenir compte du
coût dans le modèle pour faire ce type
de schéma si ça vous intéresse il ya
moyen de faire ça de manière assez
simple et je vous invite à l'occasion
aller voir le package la grammaire
encore une fois on est sur un chan
l'exemple la trajectoire c'est plutôt
quelque chose qui vous voit vous
orienter leur plein de pistes à creuser
un donc pour faire un modèle multi états
l'un d'eux donné du conte
des points d'observation à différents
moments du temps on va indiquer en fait
donc on va dire en fait notre modèle
c'est notre statut qu'on va évaluer aux
fonctions l'évolution dans le temps
maintenant statut en fonction du mois on
indique la dimension temps ici on a dit
que la variable qui qui contient les
identifiants individuel pour savoir
quelles sont les lignes qui correspond à
une même personne
datacell je donnais qu'on a préparé en
amont
q matrix et la matrice des transitions
qui a été définie ci qui dit les
transitions qui sont autorisés et puis
hop ce type c'est un paramètre qui
permet d'indiquer comment sont bien les
observations en l'occurrence ici un
petit p gagnent 1 1 10 kms m
que nos données correspondent à des
snapshots un certain moment du temps ici
tous les mois est donc en fait que les
transitions en lieu entre les taux
observés il ya d'autres options là en
cliquant sur le nom d'une fonction dans
sur l'analyse air en général ça va vous
ouvrir à l'aide de cette fonction en
ligne est le paramètre obstine il
indiqué le paramètre 2 correspond à des
cas de figure où on a en fait non pas
les points des statuts à des mots
différents moments du temps des points
d'observation mais plutôt les moment
exact où auront lieu les événements de
manière de d'avoir des informations soit
on a des points au moment des
transitions et elle connaît en fait les
éléments précis soit comme le cas
présent on a des snapshots donc des
données observées un certain moment
donné et on sera juste que du coup la
transition a lieu entre les deux ponts a
observé alors petit point quand vous
faites ce genre de modèle vous avez
souvent un ya un petit problème de
calcul
c'est tout bête mais où la sucer donné
ici c'est un petit paramètres de 2,2
de mise à échelle de certains facteurs
pour que l'ordinateur arrive à faire le
calcul
et du coup vous allez avoir un modèle et
là vous voyez ce que l'on n'obtient
qu'un modèle le plus simple
ce que oui c'est la probabilité d'être
dans chacun des statuts statut un statut
de statut trop et ça tue 4 en rouge ce
qui est ce qui est estimé par le modèle
et en bleu ce qui est réellement
observées
donc là par défaut ce qui se passe c'est
que on a fait l'hypothèse que les
probabilités de transition en fait sont
que l'intensité des transitions était
constante au cours du temps d'accord et
donc du coup ça entraîne ce lissage est
en fait on voit bien que espaces dits
les premiers mois sont pas équivalents
les transitions se fera pas au même
rythme en fait dans les premiers mois
dans les mois suivants et donc du coup
ce qu'on peut faire
ça augmente considérablement et on
calcule non c'est de considérer qu'il ya
des intensités de transition différentes
sur différentes périodes et là par
exemple on va considérer qu' on va
couper à trois mois deux mois et 24 mois
donc ça veut dire tu auras on va
calculer quatre jeux du coup de
d'intensité de transition dans les trois
premiers mois entre 3 et 12 mois entre
12 et 24 mois et après 24 mois alors ça
va entraîner du coup un temps de
quelques huiles bien plus longtemps et
là ça peut prendre encore une fois
quelques heures suivant vos machines
donc c'est juste pour vous montrer il
faut faut avoir le temps qu'on on fait
ce genre de choses mais voyez là
maintenant on a un lissage qui se fait
un petit peu mieux on voyez on a pu
avoir du coup ces changements là qu'ils
sont mieux pris en compte et on a une
meilleur ajustement entre les données
observées et les données estimées il
faut pas non plus rajouter trop de
points de coupure sinon après ça devient
on a pu assez de données pour bien voir
ce qui ce qui se passe
alors on a des fonctions qui nous
permettent de regarder la différence
entre les prévalences observés et les
préférences attendu
ainsi comptable de pourcentage je vous
ai pas angie elle utilise pareil on
fournit une fonction taibi prévalence
qui va permettre de récupérer sa seconde
d'un tableau un peu plus simple qui va
permettre de re du cours faire des
graphiques elle la voyait ça c'est ce
qu'on a observé
et ça c'est ce qu'on va modéliser alors
faire juste la modélisation a peur pas
forcément beaucoup d'informations
nouvelles à ce qui devient intéressant
c'est d'y intégrer des coûts variables
qui permettent du coup d'avoir abdiqué
multivariée et on peut du coup tenir
compte aussi des rêves dépendant du
temps comme dans un modèle de cox donc
là vous avez un modèle qui est
multivariée et voyez on a rajouté des
coûts variables
ici cette ligne-là donc là j'ai rajouté
le sexe l'âge et l'éducation alors ça
reprend encore un ton en calculant qu'il
y à un plus long l'avantagé c'est que
outre la matrice de transition aux états
et qu'on va avoir du coude et hazard
ratio des risques relatifs qui vont être
calculée par le modèle dans différentes
transitions locaux autrefois il ya une
fonction tidy pur hasard des mécènes que
j'ai développé que j'ai mise en juillet
lily ce qui permet de faciliter en fait
à l'export du résultat parce qu'il faut
comprendre qu'est klein en fait on va
avoir un sabre à sion pour chacune des
transitions possible donc chacune et
transition qu'on avait autorisés au tout
début
par ailleurs si on autorise leur
transition peu plus de pouvoir et donc
là j'ai un ratio pour les femmes
un autre passage du statut au sein du 2
et aussi pour passer du statut de haut
stature donc là vous avez on va avoir
beaucoup plus donc puisque
ici vous aurez des codes qui vont
permettre de recoller les étiquettes
mais je vais vous montrer les résultats
on obtient donc là je vous représente
tous les arabes ratio donc tous ces
risques relative tous ces risques
relatifs ce que j'ai fait pour présenter
j'ai séparé dans deux colonnes des
transitions ascendante entrée en soins
et initiation traitement contrôle de
l'infection et les transitions
descendante
donc sauf qu'il soit un arrêt traitement
et chérie neurologie donc la voyez pour
chacune de mes variable il ya même
modalités un g6 coefficient donc c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué à interpréter
que ce qu'on avait avant mais on a aussi
beaucoup plus d'informations ce qu'on
voit là en l'occurrence et que par
exemple pour les femmes par rapport aux
hommes
1 c'est que les femmes vont être plus
rapide l'année elles ont raison de la
probabilité qu'elles fassent la
transition d'entrée en soins donc c'est
à dire loin résonne probabilité beaucoup
plus élevé de faire les transitions de
type entrée en soins ou contrôle de la
faction donc c'est le passage du statut
1 à 2 et du statut 3 à 4 par contre
alors là le voyez c'est vraiment très
proche de l oms de profiter un peu plus
faible en fait de faire alors de
transitionner rapidement ses priorités
sur les intensités transition qui sont
ici en jeu dans ce type de modèle donc
l'intensité de transition du statut de
au statut 3 de l'initiation traitement
elle serait mettre un peu plus de temps
ce qu'il faut y voir là un c'est que le
sexe en fait j'ai surtout sur les deux
étapes qui sont entrés en soit son
contrôle de l'infection et sur
l'initiation du traitement
il ya peu d'écart on est borderline ça
pour les femmes mettre un tout petit peu
plus de temps
en fait ce que ça nous dit c'est que les
enjeux il se situe à ce niveau
par contre les transitions ascendante il
n'y a pas d'effet significatif même si
on voit que les femmes seraient
peut-être un petit peu moins tendance à
sortir de soins ou après chaque
biologique et encore une fois on dépasse
le 1 les intervalles de confiance sur
l'âge et c'est normal dans nos données
on avait très peu d'observations
transition descendante donc forcément on
a des dés à des intervalles de confiance
qu'ils sont larges et voyez les modèles
sur une multi et à son fils de réflexion
pour aller plus loin dans les analyses
mais surtout je ne vous conseille pas de
démarrer par des modèles de souris multi
états parce qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
complexe à mettre en oeuvre et qu' il
vaut mieux commencer avec des modèles
plus simples pour mieux comprendre ces
données voir ce qui se passe et c'est
une fois qu'on a affiné ses questions et
qu'on sait ce qu'on va les regarder
qu'on peut aller se tourner vers des
modèles qui sont de plus en plus
complexes voilà je vous propose de
m'arrêter là pour ce soir c'était du
coup notre dernière séance des
webinaires avant l'été voyez on aura
fait cinq séances sur ses analyses de
trajectoire à l'occasion prenez le temps
de relire ce chapitre la tête reposée 1
depuis le site analyseur voyez le plutôt
comme un exemple d'illustration que sur
un même jeu de données on peut avoir
recours à plein de méthodologie qui sont
différentes et même s'il ya des
résultats qui convergent entre les
différentes approches en fait c'est
qu'on se pose la question à chaque fois
un petit peu différente est souvent le
plus long problème est ce qui prend plus
de temps quand on fait une analyse c'est
pas tant la réalisation de l'analyse
elle-même c'est l'âge et il a alors le
nettoyage des données la recodification
la préparation de donner quelques gros
du code et puis après le choix de la
mode approche statistique et la bonne
manière d'appréhender sa question et ça
c'est pas un enjeu de stats c'est avant
tout un enjeu
propre à son objet la construction de
son objet qui vaut cdd pendant sa
discipline et trouver la bonne approche
artistique qui permettra du coup depuis
de poser la bonne question est d'essayer
du coup d'y trouver des réponses et
donnez vous du temps important pour
essayer surtout d'aller dans
l'interprétation du résultat
soyez vigilants a pas sûr interpréter
vos résultats et elle avait vraiment
dans contexte de vos disciplines et de
votre sujet de la littérature
voilà j'aime pas trop avancer là dessus
parce que c'est vraiment dépendant des
objets donc qui est pas le but du
webinaire proprement dit j'espère que
vous aurez du compte qu'à des billes
pour savoir où aller chercher de
l'information
si certaines méthodologies vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à re visionner
ces vidéos à tête reposée en plusieurs
fois elles seront chapitre et comme à
chaque fois
n'hésitez pas à les rechercher
l'information sur un analyseur moi même
je ne peux pas me souvenir de tout et je
passe en fait
et j'utilise analysé a beaucoup juste
pour retrouver un petit morceau de code
en disant ah c'est ça la fonction qu'il
fallait voilà en tout cas je vous
souhaite une bonne continuation avec
r les webinaires ne reprendront pas je
pense de la même manière à la rentrée
prochaine
en tout cas pas sur un rythme
hebdomadaire de toute façon il reste
disponible donc on va pas forcément
refaire les mêmes sujets qu'on ait fait
jusqu'à présent
et puis ce que j'aimerais pour ma part
c'est avoir du tour pour préparer de
nouveaux chapitres sur l'analyseur en ce
moment j'ai malheureusement pas le temps
mais j'aimerais bien finir un petit
chapitre sur les différents types de
contrats ce dans les modèles et vous
allez voir qu'il ya pas qu il n'y a pas
que la beauté de référence des contrats
ce traitement peut vous présenter
différemment ces coefficients et puis
bah du coup voilà essayer de développer
quelques nouveaux chapitres
sur l'analyseur pour appréhender
quelques nouveautés dans les package et
faire peut-être des webinaires tous les
une fois tous les deux mois tous à peu
près peut-être un tous les deux mois
mais qui aurait le temps d'être sur des
choses un peu nouveau et préparé en
avance dans tous les cas merci pour tout
à très bientôt de toute façon en ligne
restés abonnés à la chaîne est restée à
mener aussi la liste de diffusion des
webinaires pour être tenu informé à la
rentrée et je souhaite à tout ça pousse
à tout et tout
un excellent été et à très bientôt pour
un nouveau webinaire encore merci